bonjour à tous et bienvenue en normandie
dans cette voie libre spéciale dédiée
aux enjeux des élections régionales des
6 et 13 décembre prochain une émission
spéciale d'une heure avec vous feelgood
et bonjour bonjour et aujourd'hui il
sera question du littoral alors que me
le disent nos amis écrivains michel de
decker et christelle la blancherie les
normands ont beaucoup de raisons d'être
fiers parfois ils ne le savent pas et
c'est vrai que les 600 km de côtes c'est
l'un des plus grands secteurs du
littoral des coupes d'europe
et bien c'est en normandie se passe
beaucoup de choses et c'est vrai
également que ici à sherbrooke ont un
petit peu de tout on a de la haute
technologie on à l'agriculture ont la
pêche alors et on l'a l'éolien marin qui
se profile c'est pas obligatoire vous
toujours facile à gérer ou pour parler
avec nos invités
ils vont parler de l'économie de la mer
et bien le cadre idéal a cité la mer de
cherbourg octeville cette ancienne gare
transatlantique avait passé dans la rade
il ya ce sont 13 ans le titanic pour une
avant dernière escale avant son naufrage
cette gare à une nouvelle vie depuis
2002 elle est devenue un parc ludique
dédié à l'exploration du monde sous
marin à la découverte des grandes
profondeurs et pour explorer l'économie
de la mer cinq invités politiques
stéphane travert tête de liste ps prg
dans la manche actuel député et
conseiller régional de basse normandie
en charge de la pêche de l'aquaculture
et des ressources marines
monsieur le député à vos côtés jérôme
vie en nouvelle bonjour je vous vous
êtes conseiller municipal conseiller
communautaire à saint lô et vous êtes
conseiller régional sortant pour
qu'europe écologie les verts merci
d'être avec nous valérie varennes du
parti communiste tête de liste front de
gauche pour le département de la manche
vous êtes technicienne dans la filière
de démantèlement de sous-marins à
dessein à cherbourg t'as fait ça ça vous
david bergen bonjour vous êtes vous
représentez les républicains au sein de
la liste des républicains de lui dit et
des divers prend toujours pas de souci
éthique et ça fait quand même quelques
gens vous êtes conseiller municipal et
conseiller communautaire à octeville
cherbourg vous êtes un recueil vous avez
35 ans à vos côtés jean jacques noëls
tête de liste front national dans la
manche vous êtes également le secrétaire
départemental du front national agent de
prévention en hygiène et sécurité
environnementale à dcns aussi h
amour à vos côtés également emmanuel
chaunu qui n'hésitera pas à dégainer ses
crayons et ses feuilles pour nous
croquer tous pendant ces débats et
d'ailleurs il a commencé en parlant de
du feu à bord de la normandie le front
national fait un petit peu peur ici
comme ailleurs peut-être un peu moins
que dans leurs pas de calais quoique on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir mais on peut
commencer peut-être aussi vous savez que
depuis la semaine dernière on demande à
nos téléspectateurs qui sont aussi des
électeurs ce qu'ils pensent des
élections régionales de la réunification
de la façon dont se présentent ces
élections c'est pas obligatoirement
faciles on a eu l'occasion de s'en
apercevoir également ici à cherbourg en
compagnie d'élise ferrer et de sylvain
rouil ont des cours à 100%
quoi pas parce que la leur mort 10 et la
normandie c'était ridicule de l'avoir
divisé en deux
j'ai pas trop d'avis là dessus je m'en
fiche un peu en fait
roberson mort je pense que rien aux
mentalités sont un petit peu différente
donc ça va mettre du temps je pense ça
permet de faire beaucoup de choses
ensemble quoi ce jour professionnel
peut-être comme l'industrie peut-être
sur le commerce c'est très important
d'un point de vue identitaire
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on regarde cette
identité forte de basse-normandie de
haute-normandie la passion grandit et
ben va être comme ça va être les et
surtout nous le nord-cotentin ans
éloigné de tous on veut décentraliser la
france mais il ya des choses qui qui
reste tellement centralisée que quand on
habite en province où on se sent
délaissée quoi il fait beau plusieurs
fois par jour en normandie là il pleut
actuellement à chabot un premier tour de
table pour après ces réactions justement
les bas-normands hooper et puisqu'il
s'intéresse vraiment à ces élections
c'est à travers réunir la normandie est
un immense défi c'est répondre aux
demandes de proximité de nos concitoyens
la région elle agit dans le concret et
dans le concitoyen dans le pour les
concitoyens normand que nous sommes
l'éducation formation environnement
agriculture pêche développement
économique
la région est aujourd'hui une dans
l'action de proximité
je crois que nos concitoyens ne doivent
pas craindre cette réunification c'est
une chance que nous avons pour porter
plus de projets et pour développer notre
territoire tous ensemble c'est pas vous
donner la parole parce que vous êtes
dans la lumière
c'est bien d'aller dans la lumière de
temps en temps mais la vraie trop
peut-être
oui effectivement pour la normandie en
fait on peut parler de de réunification
historique parce que c'est ça elle a du
sens effectivement aujourd'hui par
rapport à d'autres régions où c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué
la haute et la basse normandie le nom à
nom commun donc vraiment une
réunification mais je crois que le
problème de ce raté de cette rééducation
c'est qu'elle arrive dans une réforme
territoriale est ce que les gens ont
peur effectivement on voit bien c'est la
perte de proximité
donc il faudra vraiment travailler au
plus près des citoyens au plus près des
normands pour pas effectivement qu'il
ait le sentiment d'oubli d'être oublié
le nord cotentin c'est vrai que peut
être loin de la capitale trois roues en
est vraiment leur donner vraiment le
sentiment qu'on sera vraiment toujours
au plus près au niveau de la santé de la
formation de l'industrie ce sont
vraiment des enjeux à jouer demain très
rapidement jacques noël votre réaction
la réunification se fait longtemps que
nous le réclamions front national lors
des dernières échéances régionales n'ont
pas attendu que l'europe nous l'imposent
c'est vrai que c'est une chance pour la
normandie d'autres régions elles vont
perdre leur identité nous
nous la retrouvons un peu de manière
naturelle puisque c'est vrai que ce
n'était pas pas très naturel de séparer
la haute et la basse normandie n'y a
qu'une
historiquement il y avait qu une
normandie c'est un retour aux sources et
serait que le défi des élus ce sera de
ne pas perdre cette proximité avec les
gens de la manche notamment puisque
puisque nous sommes dans la manche
je crois que la réunification est en
effet une chance pour la normandie et
les normands puisqu'elle est un vecteur
d'identité c'est la deuxième région la
plus connue au monde après à la
californie je crois qu'il faut se servir
de ce vecteur aujourd'hui de puissance
et de développement et en même temps la
réunification ne sera réussie que si
elle fonctionne sur un double équilibre
l'équilibré entre les métropoles
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
pris un engagement fort avec comme
capitale politique est un également un
équilibre entre nos territoires les
territoires oubliés notre tradition nos
terroirs que nous voulons cultiver et la
difficulté guénels comme le montre
d'ailleurs notre ami dessinateur chez
lui c'est de faire le lien entre une
basse normandie qui passe à tort ou à
raison comme étant très rurale et une
haute normandie qui passe à tort ou à
raison
vous savez trop peut-être trouvé
industriels la vérité peut être entre
les deux je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais je crois que c'est un peu ça
voilà gérons bien nouveau dans la
lumière mais on vous écoute merci
écoutez c'est une élection qui va se
dérouler dans un contexte tout à fait
particulier donc ça a été dit par mes
prédécesseurs il ya la réunification la
normandie il ya aussi la région qui voit
ses compétences renforcées par la loi
nôtre mais comme vous le savez tout ceci
c'est le contexte de la coop 21 donc la
conférence internationale sur le climat
qui vise à réduire absolument les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
que à l'horizon 2100 on n'est pas un
climat qui dépassent plus de deux degrés
et je crois que c'est l'occasion de
rappeler le rôle des collectivités et
les compétences de la région qui peut
jouer alors en termes d'emploi en termes
de transport en termes de formation pour
réduire ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre est ce que nous nous appelons les
écologistes la transition écologistes et
la transition énergétique et je vous
remercie d'organiser ces débats aussi
qui permet de mettre en lumière les
compétences des régions parce que trop
souvent ce débat des élections
régionales est nationalisée donc voilà
je tenais aussi à vous remercier pendant
l'organisation de ses déboires en
normandie merci beaucoup
on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet en
parlant de l'économie de la mer en
commençant par les énergies marines
renouvelables puisque l'europe la
demande et la loi sur le grenelle
l'environnement l'a validé en 2020 23%
de l'énergie consommée doit venir les
énergies renouvelables on est
actuellement un peu plus de 10 % il ya
donc de la marge
parmi les outils pour une énergie propre
les énergies marines renouvelables
les hydroliennes où les éoliennes et la
lave normandie a peut-être sa carte à
jouer elle dispose du littoral du vent
et des courants et notamment le spot
dans la manche le raz blanchard
depuis quatre ans la normandie est
d'ailleurs largement investi pour
accueillir ces nouvelles technologies
notamment juste à côté de cette cité de
la mer sur le port de cherbourg sylvain
rouil du vent des courants 600 km de
côtes la normandie possède les atouts
nécessaires au développement des
énergies marines renouvelables au large
des plages du débarquement 75 éoliennes
devraient être installés c'est l'un des
trois parcs offshore actuellement en
projet dans la région avec ceux du
tréport et de fécamp pour construire ces
éoliennes de porc le havre et cherbourg
ont été retenus le premier par areva
le second par alstom à cherbourg
les travaux pour accueillir les futures
usines ont commencé il ya cinq mois
un chantier titanesque 39 hectares sont
en train d'être gagnée sur la mer
côté industriel un permis de construire
pour une usine de pales a été déposé
l'autre usine destinée au mas est elle
au point mort
350 emplois directs sont annoncés contre
500 au départ au havre rien de concret
pour le moment
mais en octobre areva et son partenaire
à dwayne sont sortis d'un silence
inquiétant confirmant la construction de
deux usines d'éoliennes qui joue hanescu
vers des usines un temps remise en cause
selon l'industriel les dossiers de
permis de construire serait en cours
les travaux pourraient débuter au plus
tard en 2018
des promesses que les collectivités
compte bien voir concrétiser elle qui
ont déjà injecté des millions d'euros
dans la sphère nous travaillons depuis
longtemps avec le maire du havre avec
areva pour qu areva s'engage sur le
havre de la même façon qu alstom doit
s'engager sur cherbourg mais les usines
elles se font pas en 24 heures
personne ne sait vraiment comment la
filière industrielle va s'organiser
entre cherbourg et le havre mais aussi
saint nazaire ou brest
les acteurs sont nombreux quant au
calendrier annoncé
il pourrait continuer à évoluer
notamment en cas de recours devant la
justice
l'eau l'air le vent ça souffle ici bas
oui emmanuel regard de cette presqu'île
du cotentin les umr stéphane travert
justement c'est la filière d'avenir
seront remis encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes
oui des incertitudes mais en même temps
nous avons une grande chance c'est que
nous assistons à l'émergence d'une
nouvelle filière et nous la créons de
toute pièce et je crois que c'est un
formidable défi auquel nous devons
répondre aujourd'hui notre territoire
est un territoire exemplaire en matière
de mix énergétique filières nucléaires
existantes aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui la
filière des énergies marines
renouvelables
la amy signé par le président de la
république en octobre 2013
à la cité de la mer va permettre aussi
de développer les l'hydrolien sur lequel
nous aussi nous comptons beaucoup grâce
au raz blanchard ça a été soulignée à
l'intérieur de votre de votre reportage
donc à partir de là créer cette filière
s'est développé l'emploi c'est faire de
la formation et faire en sorte que nous
puissions être un territoire innovant
bien évidemment et porteurs de ces
nouvelles filières et ce qu'il me semble
aujourd'hui très important a souligné
alors on a l'impression que les choses
sont relativement claires entre la haute
et la basse normandie à droite ça n'a
pas toujours été évident puisqu'il ya eu
quand même un petit débat entre eux ou
va s'installer lusinchi la fabriquer les
éoliennes
on avait dit c'est le havre après on
entendu monsieur morin alors monsieur
enfin le maire du havre edouard philippe
évidemment été très porteur de cette
idée on l'a entendu ensuite monsieur
morin dire alors non il va ya voir la
construction des pales à cherbourg est
ce que les choses sont claires dans
votre camp oui les choses sont
parfaitement claires hervé morin l'a dit
elle a rappelé nous soutenons les
énergies marines renouvelables nous
souhaitons le développement de ces
énergies marines renouvelables mais sans
aveuglement idéologique bien sûr que ces
énergies vont apporter un plus pour la
normandie qui doit à cette occasion
s'affirmer comme une terre d'excellence
énergétique et nous le souhaitons
véritablement accompagner la montée en
puissance de ces énergies
mais en même temps que nous disons cela
est que nous voulons conforter le port
du havre et le port de cherbourg qui a
un hinterland relativement faibles et
pour lequel ces énergies marines
renouvelables sont si importantes en
même temps que nous disons cela eh bien
nous affirmons également la fierté de
l'excellence de notre filière nucléaire
parce que le mix énergétique c'est
toutes les énergies nous avons un
véritable sujet de clivage sur ce sujet
les socialistes et les écologistes et le
front de gauche qui partent sur des
listes séparées sur cette question ne
sont pas d'accord sur la question du
nucléaire
nicolas mayer rossignol lui-même affirme
ses doutes sur le p r eh bien moi je
veux le dire ces quatre salariés d'areva
et me l'a dit il la déclare la rigolade
déclaré il a déclaré vous savez très
bien que vous avez un accord électoral
que vous devez passer qui vous
compliquer les choses pour tenir un
discours j'ai avec les salariés si vous
voulez bien
si vous voulez bien je vais terminer un
mort aux rats mais les salariés du
nucléaire
les syndicats que nous avons rencontrés
avec hervé morin de la même manière que
les dirigeants attendent aujourd'hui un
discours qui les conforte qui les
rassure la loi de transition énergétique
du 15 août dernier et eu pour nous une
mauvaise loi nous soutenons la
diversification le mix énergétique
mais cette loi aujourd'hui avec le
plafonnement de l'énergie nucléaire à 63
gigawatts est une mauvaise loi parce que
elles pourraient aboutir d'ici 2025 à la
fermeture de 24 réacteurs ce qui serait
une 4è catastrophe pour la normandie
pour la france parce que je le dis
le nucléaire est une chance pour la
normandie mais c'est aussi une nécessité
pour la france en terme d'économie
d'énergie en termes également de coups
parce que c'est une électricité à bas
coûts qui y est produite et en termes
d'indépendance pour notre pays c'est à
travers peut-être sur les futurs
d'alliance avec europe écologie
des éléments de réponse mais à la région
nous travaillons avec europe écologie
les verts sur un constat qui est tout à
fait simple c'est à dire que la région
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas la compétence
bien évidemment d'arrêter une filière
comme celle du nucléaire mais pourtant
elles travaillent sur les sujets de
formation elle accompagne la filière à
travers la formation professionnelle et
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui sur le p r
ce sont ce qu'on appelle les formations
et d'hec et bien nous faisons en sorte
que les salariés qui travaillent
aujourd'hui sur le père puisse demain
être formé pour venir travailler sur les
terre-pleins que nous sommes en train de
construire et sur laquelle la région
vient d'investir 100 millions d'euros
sur le sujet de la filière nucléaire
nous sommes parfaitement au clair là
dessus nous soutenons bien évidemment
cette cette filière est aujourd'hui nous
continuerons à faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une complémentarité avec l'émergence
de la filière des énergies marines
renouvelables
bien évidemment et de l'autre côté nous
souhaitons faire de cette
complémentarité des énergies à le mix
énergétique qui soit porteur d'une image
forte pour notre territoire mais attends
monsieur travers vous avez voté la loi
de transition énergétique tourner le dos
à notre filiale oppose pas les énergies
les unes aux autres et une chose que
nous négocions drive à terre mais xsf
soirée les salariés d'arrêt de la
production des lourds se déroulèrent le
dossier de la production d'énergie à
partir de l'éolien ou de l'hydro les
salariés de l'affairé ça que cette fois
tourner le dos à l'excellence et ne
prenez pas tout votre temps de parole
monsieur marguerite parce qu'après il
est mal alors un ou quand même on
précise que en haute normandie notamment
mais pas seulement
on forme justement les personnels qui
travaillent dans les centres du caire on
les forme déjà fait avec du matériel
très performant qui subventionnait
d'ailleurs on trouve par le conseil
régional de haute normandie alors vous
avez parlé de mix énergétique
là on a deux thèses qui s'opposent
carrément c'est celle du front national
et celle d'europe écologie les verts
on va vous donner la parole monsieur
virlouvet pour commencer clairement vous
même si encore une fois et monsieur
travers a eu un rôle de dire la
compétence de la région n'est pas
directement lié au nucléaire qui relève
des fonctions régaliennes de l'état
ça veut pas dire pour autant que
vous en désintéresser bien évidemment et
pour vous carrément il faut laisser
tomber le nucléaire est passé aux
énergies on va dire bonnaire le
renouvelable etc
mais quelque part je pense que peut-être
que les écologistes peuvent mettre tout
le monde d'accord c'est quand monsieur
marguerite dit c'est une véritable
catastrophe pour la filière nucléaire
que la loi de transition énergétique et
que d'annoncer qu'il faudra réduire
diviser par deux la production nucléaire
à l'avenir de toute façon on sait très
bien que pour arrêter la filière
nucléaire elle va pas s'arrêter du jour
au lendemain
et donc nous les écologistes ont misé
beaucoup sur la filière d'excellence de
démantèlement et en plus la france peut
devenir une filière d'excellence
internationale sur le démantèlement de
toutes les installations nucléaires
donc on sait bien que il faudra des
travailleurs et il faudra les former et
c'est là où la région intervient elle
n'intervient pas directement dans la la
production au niveau 2 le père mais par
contre sur la formation des ouvriers
notamment ceux qui travaillent sur le
chantier de le père donc je crois qu'il
faut pas s'inquiéter il faut pas il faut
pas agiter des chiffons rouges vis-à-vis
des salariés du nucléaire je crois qu'on
peut il faut d'ailleurs préserver ses
compétences parce qu'on en aura besoin
de materner parvenez moi vous vous êtes
pour la red le père qui est en
construction qui coûte très cher etc et
vous voudriez on emploie les salariés
actuellement c'est en train de
construire cette paire pour le
démanteler mais de toute façon
excusez moi mais on le dit depuis le
début
cette p r que c'est une gabegie une
gabegie financière
c'est un budget initial de 3 milliards 3
qu'on en a dix milliards et demi qu'il
était vraiment annoncée pour 2012 et que
là on nous annonce 2020 exactement
donc c'est un gouffre financier c'est
une catastrophe industrielle
concrètement puisque celui en finlande
il ne fonctionne toujours pas en chine
s'est toujours pas prévu donc à l'heure
où le demande à tout le monde aux
collectivités aux citoyens de faire
attention à l'argent public de voir
s'envoler
ce budget c'est bon voilà c'est une
hérésie quoi donc je crois que c'est le
mix énergétique les écologistes le
demande depuis très longtemps
enfin enfin il arrive c'est une vraie
chance pour nos territoires
ça a été dit il ya un potentiel
hydrolien et un potentiel éolien je
pense que ca va permettre au cotentin
notamment ici de se diversifier de ne
plus être dans la mono industrie
nucléaire mais j'attire juste une
attention c'est que par rapport aux
emplois qui soient annoncées c'est
important et la région là son rôle à
jouer
c'est de faire travailler des
sous-traitants et de former les salariés
cécile dans le territoire pour que ça
profite à tout le territoire et pas
uniquement à cherbourg jean jacques noël
vous vous demandez france elle demande
un moratoire
justement sur les énergies marines
renouvelables non pas sur les accords
sur les énergies marines renouvelables
sur l'évolution l'éolien offshore est et
reste puisque pour nous la gabegie et
l'hérésie et se situe ici sur l'éolien
notamment
double-double gabegie enfin double
hérésie écologique d'abord puisque que
faites vous quand vous avez fermé une
partie de vos centrales nucléaires pour
remplacer par de l'éolien en situation
anticyclonique hivernale c'est à dire
sans vent vous n'avez plus d'éoliennes
vous n'avez plus d'énergie puisque ça
tourne pas et vous êtes obligé de le
compenser par des parts des usines
thermiques des centrales thermiques
c'est ce qu'a fait l'allemagne est
quelqu'un qui a entraîné une explosion
du taux de carbone et les particules
rejetées dans l'atmosphère puisque
l'allemagne maintenant les plus gros
pollueurs européens ce qui concerne le
carbone le problème du mix énergétique
c'est que les régions haute et basse
normandie ont tout injectés dans
l'éolien nous nous nous souhaitons avoir
un éventail plus large soutenir la
médiation la métallisation l'hydrolien
mais aussi l'hydrogène qui pour nous est
une filière d'avenir et d'excellence et
surtout continuer de soutenir la filière
électronucléaire française et notamment
en normandie et nous nous soutenons le p
r nous pensons que c'est un directeur
qui est les plus sûrs qui était conçu et
qui va être construit qui va être fini
bien sûr il ya des retards bien sûr il
ya un dépassement de coûts mais ce qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que nous avons
été 15 ans en france sans construire
deux centrales nous avons perdu un
savoir faire
le père donc ce sera une haie sera
vraiment compétitif pour nous dans les
années à venir si on arrive à le vendre
et à l'exporter nous soutenons ce cette
construction alors l'action des taxes
s'adapter dans l'autre sens s'il n'est
pas nucléaire vous n'auriez rien dans
l'infrastructure alors soyez content
puis c'est du boulot oui mais je suis
aussi à signaler que les problèmes qu'on
lui signale sûr sûr sûr le père sont des
problèmes qualité qu'on remonte plus
maintenant qu'il ya 20 ou 30 ans quand
on signe à des problèmes qualité en
industrie il faut quand même il faut
quand même souligner qu'avant c'était en
personne communiquer sur le sur les
problèmes maintenant on a une hyper
communication sur tout ce qui est
déviation qualité dans le domaine
industriel et c'est un peu normal qu'on
qu'on soit confronté à un genre de
problème sachant en plus que le père est
une tête de série un prototype qui n'a
jamais été construit alors vous
travaillez à dcns
valérie varennes aussi qui défend le
front de gauche
alors vous n'êtes pas du tout du même
bord vous vous estimez que c'est le mrc
est une opportunité notamment pour dcns
qui a une opportunité de trouver un
autre souffle peut être oui
l'opportunité mais ce faux pas que ce
soit l'opportunité on va dire seulement
de récupérer de l'argent pour ce soit
l'opportunité aussi de développer
l'emploi développer la formation
aujourd'hui effectivement on a parlé
tout à l'heure des éoliennes du raz
blanchard
il ya déjà eu une première série au
niveau de paimpol et bréhat ces
hydroliennes aurait dû être fabriquée en
fait sur le site de cherbourg
elles n'auront pas été elles ont été des
cols le localiser dans la fabrication
donc on voit bien aujourd'hui que le
problème l'argent public va aux
industries françaises mais ne va pas
directement en fait aux salariés et je
crois que le débat aujourd'hui
en fait il est important dans la dans la
perspective de la coupe d'un t1
on devra aller vers la diversification
énergétique peut être effectivement
sortir demain pas demain parce qu'on
sait que c'est du nucléaire mais ce
qu'on voit aussi aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
n'a pas fait des deux de sondage auprès
des citoyens on n'a pas regardé les
besoins énergétiques de la france
est ce qu'on met en place actuellement
c'est une transition énergétique qui va
aussi dans la case de deux entreprises
une caste j'arrive à une cave une cache
d f
le service public qui a fait ses preuves
quant au prix du kilowattheure demain
quel prix on vendra le kilowattheure
effectivement il ya des énergies à
creuser on l'a vu l'hydrogène l'éolien
mais le gros truc la recherche ça va
être le stockage de l'électricité
lorsque demain on aura compris comment
stocker effectivement l'électricité eh
bien on aura peut-être là une vraie
carte à jouer est vraiment un atout
énergétique mais vraiment il faut
sortent enfin le débat de se dire oui
pour ou contre le nucléaire aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai débat avec la population
un vrai débat public il y a plein
d'endroits où les gens sont représentés
que soient les citoyens les syndicats
les entreprises
un vrai débat avec la population et
arrêter de mentir aux personnes le p r
si ça a coûté de l'argent aussi
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on essaye de
faire rentrer au chausse pied des fois
dans des enveloppes financières des gros
projets qui aujourd'hui peuvent pas
rentrer et voilà c'est vrai pour le p r
c'est vrai pour plein d'autres projets
une question politique qui vous concerne
au front gauche et chez europe ecologie
les verts on a vu à dire qu'il y avait
des alliances entre partis communistes
qui dirige la ville de dieppe et à côté
europe ecologie les verts dans un
contexte duclair très fort puisque pour
lier palmer se trouve juste à côté de
dieppe et c'est vrai que ça peut
paraître comme étant un débat au sein
même du conseil régional on l'a vu le
temps bandits parce que c'est aussi un
débat entre vous en basse normandie est
globalement en normandie dans le cadre
que ces élections régionales dans le
sens où effectivement europe ecologie
les verts est vent debout si vous passez
l'expression contre le nucléaire et vous
finalement vous y voyez aussi un intérêt
sur le plan de l'emploi vous venez de
vous le dire vous n'êtes pas la seule
dans votre formation politique
ce qu'on n'est pas d'accord c'est
vraiment par rapport donc je vous disais
au nucléaire aujourd'hui on voit avec ce
qui se passe localement avec
l'entreprise areva
je crois qu'il faut penser aussi à une
filière nucléaire j'irai française c'est
à dire du début jusqu'à la fin de la
filière on parle du début donc c'est la
conception du combustible
jusqu'à son retraitement et jusqu'au
démantèlement demain on aura des grands
projets effectivement dans le nucléaire
des grands projets de carénage des
grands projets de démantèlement avec qui
comment on va le faire et donc c'est
vraiment l'enjeu de demain aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on ne peut pas ne pas dire
aujourd'hui on va pas sortir du
nucléaire
on va vers une diversification
énergétique il la faut absolument mais
il faudra que ça se fasse avec une paye
ans et elle se fera il faut qu'elle se
passe au niveau de la région de l'argent
public va être quand même octroyé aux
entreprises parce qu'il faudra les
soutenir
iliad est quand même des craintes par
rapport aux en deux semaines en
industrie il ya de l'argent à investir
et des entreprises à construire il ya de
la formation à m parce qu'on est
vraiment nous au niveau de la normandie
dans le début en fait de cette danse et
énergie et on voit bien des fois que
malheureusement on a pris même du retard
par rapport à d'autres pays européens
au niveau même de la france et des fois
par rapport à d'autres régions
alors parler maintenant de la pêche
l'économie de la mer ce sont aussi les
poissons les huîtres les bulles ou
encore les coquilles la saison est en
cours et des pêcheurs cette économie là
a beaucoup souffert 20% d'effectifs en
moins en dix ans à cause de la
diminution des stocks de poissons des
réglementations européennes la réduction
de la flottille division par deux du
nombre de navires depuis 83
il reste à peu près 500 bateaux sur le
littoral normand un flip on va écouter à
ce sujet debout la france voilà lancé
lise non pardonnez moi c'est lise la
boyne qui est debout la france 76 lise
ligne la voile dont qui se trouve au
tréport alors vous le savez sans doute
les pêcheurs du tréport là aussi ne sont
pas contents parce qu'ils estiment que
le champ éolien qui va s'installer entre
le tréport et diop est justement
installé à l'endroit où ils vont pêcher
c'est une pêche de proximité
alors on écoute lille lyne la voile aile
pour elle se rapproche du point de vue
des pêcheurs elle nous dit pourquoi
avec ce dupont aignan nous voulons qu'il
y ait des écoles pour former la pêche le
monde de la pêche ce sont des mondes qui
sont aujourd'hui oubliées nous voulons
qu'il y ait des possibilités de succéder
et nous ne voulons pas que tout ça parte
à vau l'eau nous nous avons une réelle
envie de préserver ce patrimoine encore
une fois qu'ils imaginent importe de
pêche aujourd'hui c'est la saison du
hareng il ya plein de monde qui vient
parce que c'est ici et pas ailleurs que
les que les harengs viennent frayer
depuis des années c'est la zone de frai
la zone de reproduction ancestrales et
ceux ci on installe de telles machines
dans ces zones là on sait très bien que
ça disparaîtra alors effectivement nous
ce qu'on veut c'est aider
par les votes des budgets que ce soit
pas destructif mais ce sont au contraire
constructif
david margueritte est-ce que la pêche
c'est une piste de croissance pour la
région
oui en effet pour rebondir sur ce qui
vient d'être dit en effet il ya des
conflits d'usagé de la mer à gérer
notamment au tréport et des
compensations à trouver sur pour les
pêcheurs 3 choisissez ailleurs au
danemark oui il faut le faire je pense
que la profession il retrouve son compte
trois choses sur la pêche pense d'abord
l'aide à la modernisation le fait amp
les fonds européens d'ed wood fera date
des affaires maritimes et de la pêche
aujourd'hui ses 18 millions pour la
normandie réunifiée
c'est plus de 13 millions pour la
basse-normandie qui est une région en
transition quatre millions et demi à peu
près pour la haute normandie il faut se
servir de ces fonds en accompagnant bien
sûr les professionnels qui sont les
mieux placés pour savoir ce qu'il faut
faire de la flottille pour moderniser
l'outil de pêche
deuxième chose le renouvellement de la
flottille nous avons une proposition
avec hervé morin qui est ce fonds de 100
millions d'euros qui peut permettre
d'entrer dans le capital de certaines
activités économiques dont la pêche
et puis je voudrais terminer par un
troisième point la normandie est une
marque je le disais tout à l'heure et
nous souhaitons rééquilibrer le rapport
de force
la normandie est une grande terre pour
les pour les pêcheurs je vois ce qui a
été fait à la région notamment avec le
pôle mer bretagne qui était un pôle
d'innovation dans laquelle la basse
normandie est rentré 213 de ces pôles
ont été constitués huit seulement ont
été labellisés pour la basse-normandie
moi je le dis je souhaite que la
normandie se dote d'un outil régional
pour accompagner nos pêcheurs en
normandie pour défendre notre filière
ici plutôt que d'aller servir des
intérêts d'autres régions mais ça marche
on a bien compris ce que voulait dire
mais quelque part vous n'avez pas
complètement dit quel était votre point
de vue par rapport au problème et là je
reprends les propos de nathalie des
sites sur internet qui nous dit le port
de cherbourg c'est plus ce que c'était
sur le plan de la pêche c'est vraiment
ça devient très grave et on a entendu
l'hymne lavoine dire la même chose au
tréport elle représente en quelque sorte
un peu les pêcheurs du tréport qu'on
vraiment peur de ce qui va se passer
avec ce champ éolien
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut leur répondre
d'après vous moi je le dis franchement
il faut trouver des compensations les
compensations que l'on peut trouver
c'est par exemple et nîmes la caisse
sociale des pêcheurs trouvaient des
exonérations de charges
parce que en effet les champs éoliens
pose des problèmes je le disais il ya
des conflits d'usagé et c'est là que la
piste de la compensation il faut que la
mère puisse être utilisé par tous par
l'activité économique par les
plaisanciers
par les pêcheurs mais en même temps moi
je lui dis je lui ai dit tout à l'heure
les énergies marines renouvelables
nous les soutenons nous ne voulons pas
tourner le dos à ces énergies d'ailleurs
c'est le gouvernement précédent qui les
a lancés il ya un consensus sur ce sujet
donc il faut trouver des réponses
concrètes à apporter d exonérer
d'exonérations de charges au niveau
gouvernemental
dz amplifié au niveau régional vous ai
cité le fait amp 18 millions pour la
région normandie c'est considérable et
puis l'aide renouvellement de la
flottille que nous proposons avec hervé
morin et avec le fonds de 200 millions
que nous allons dotées en fonds
d'amorçage pendant dix ans bien vers
louvain
quand vous préserver la ressource quand
tous les voisins européens ne sont pas
soumis aux mêmes règles
on pense notamment en conflit avec les
anglais en début de saison sur la
coquille par exemple alors effectivement
là en sort un petit peu du cadre
régional
c'est justement au niveau européen que
des discussions doivent avoir lieu en
bonne intelligence pour que pour que
chacun puisse s'y retrouver
après pour revenir sur la question qui a
été soulevée par le spectateur sur le
port de pêche du cerveau qui n'est plus
ce qu'il était voilà tout à fait donc je
pense que on peut tout à fait concilier
différentes activités vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure le danemark ou alors il
faut au travers d'études d'impact je
pense que nous sommes pas tous des
spécialistes de la biologie marine
je pense qu'il faut et d'ailleurs avant
l'implantation des champs éoliens il y à
des études d'impact pour essayer
d'évaluer où les 29% ou les hauts
plateaux où les implantations sont les
meilleurs et on a vu il ya des exemples
au danemark qui montrent que au
contraire ça peut être des zones où les
poissons peuvent sont préservés et où
ils peuvent
frayez se reproduire et se
réinvestissent les lieux exactement
donc je pense que c'est des activités
qui peuvent finalement être
complémentaires faut juste le faire en
bonne intelligence au bon endroit et
finalement je pense qu'on peut régler
parfois des conflits d'usagé qui parfois
est paré c'est à vous qu'on ne pouvait
pas comme on dit résoudre départ quoi
alors une information c'est vrai quesnel
que au large du tréport il est question
finalement d'installer - d'éoliennes
plus puissante plus éloignées les unes
des autres et je peux vous dire pour
être allé sur place et a rencontré les
pêcheurs ça suffit pas à les calmer pour
le moment en tout cas
alors que je voulais dire aussi c'est
qu'il faudrait sortir du champ enfin le
prisme que de la pêche j'irai les
poissons les bateaux il faut l'élargir
beau
populaire je pense que quand on parle de
la pète il ya toute l'industrie qui va
aussi avec la pêche la transformation
l'aquaculture il ya beaucoup de métiers
qui sont liées à la pêche
et c'est vrai que par rapport
effectivement au travail qui est fait
par rapport à ces élections régionales
je le vois bien quand on quand on
regarde effectivement notre port de
cherbourg on a l'impression parfois
qu'effectivement la criée semble un
petit peu morte
et pourtant ces cinq tonnes de poisson
qui transitent sur le port de cherbourg
donc je crois que ce qui est mort en
fait c'est la façon dont le poisson
arrive l'eau façon dont il repart donc
c'est vraiment en fait une économie on
voit bien de transport à mettre autour
de nos ports de vraiment des changes et
au niveau de la région il faudra même
vraiment mettre un pool de 1 paul de la
mère avait vraiment quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de ces questions et qui lie
tous les métiers en fait ensemble voilà
alors notre ami je lui bon port les
boîtes de sardines normande c'est vrai
qu'on a plutôt tendance du côté de la
bretagne et de concarneau mais après
tout pourquoi pas c'est vrai qu'il faut
diversifier les productions
qu'est ce que vous en pensez et les
mettre en valeur là encore un avenir
pour la pêche ou alors un présent qu'il
faut développer mais comment non moi je
vois déjà dénoncé le double discours de
l'ump et du parti socialiste et de leurs
alliés européens puisque pour des
raisons électorales locales et
ils soutiennent la filière pêche au
moins en paroles mais en mettant le
système européen en place ils ont tué la
pêche française
voilà ça va le phénomène va encore
s'accentuer
on nous annonce un moratoire sur le bar
pendant six mois on nous annonce une
baisse des quotas de 20 à 25% sur
l'aiglefin la réelle merlan et une
obligation de ramener les prises à terre
les prises non viable ce qui va prendre
de la place dans les cales des bateaux
où ils n'ont plus de place pour pour
mettre les poissons qui sont
susceptibles d'être vendus voilà donc ça
ce sont des mesures qui sont qui vont
êtres qui sont annoncées qui vont être
débattues au niveau de l'europe au mois
de décembre ça va être encore un peu
plus une catastrophe pour la pêche pour
la pêche normande en particulier et puis
on nous parlait de l'éolien en nous
disant qu'on avait créé 350 emplois sur
cherbourg
il faut savoir que si les parcs éoliens
on voit le jour au large du tréport ses
800 emplois 800 emplois dans la pêche
dans la transformation et dans le
tourisme qui vont disparaître
voilà donc nous nous sommes contre
l'éolien pour ces raisons là et nous
sommes pour soutenir la pêche est encore
une fois non pas de double discours pour
nous l'europe c'est une catastrophe et
le système qu'ils ont mis en place
volontairement est une catastrophe pour
la pêche française
nous nous souhaitons au niveau de la
région soutenir les investissements
soutenir la modernisation de la flotte
aider à l'installation des jeunes
pêcheurs à ceux qui souhaitent investir
se lancer dans le métier
et puis et puis formez forme et soutenir
les écoles de qui forme aux métiers de
aux métiers de la mer ainsi que la
recherche et aux verts mais monsieur
noël par le voc les paroles moi je
réponds en actes la normandie
aujourd'hui c'est ce sont des budgets
consacrés à la pêche 18 millions d'euros
consacrés par l'europe pour aider notre
filière qui est une spécificité dans le
territoire normand la pêcheries
artisanales dans normandie c'est quelque
chose que nous devons porter et défendre
nous avons eu des plans de sortie de
flotte successifs qui ont fait ce qu
aujourd'hui nous avons moins de bateaux
bien évidemment nous faut aussi protéger
la ressource
il nous faut aussi accompagner les
pêcheurs qui sont ici nous nous
présentons un parlement de la mer le
parlement de la mer c'est quoi c'est ce
qui va permettre demain de réunir
l'ensemble des acteurs du domaine
maritime pour avoir un dialogue pour
avoir un dialogue notamment lorsque l'on
veut implanter un champ éolien pour
avoir un dialogue avec les pêcheurs
lorsqu'il s'agit de
on réguler la ressource aujourd'hui 80%
des espèces pêchées en manche font hors
quota donc aujourd'hui vous parler d'un
certain nombre de difficultés liées aux
quotas nous ne sommes pas concernés sur
notre terre notre pêcheries pas si nous
allons être concernés et que sur le bar
je suis d'accord mais sur le reste mais
les pêcheurs devraient rien des mon
chéri de coquillages imposer la jac où
il allait au lien aujourd'hui très bien
aux européens vont nous permettre dans
la fois de valoriser nos productions de
valoriser la commercialisation de ses
productions de porter l'image de la
normandie le label pêcher en normandie
c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous
comptons beaucoup bien évidemment très
bien à la défection encore faut-il
qu'ils aient dépêché sur le plan de
modernisation de la flotte
on nous explique qu'il faut sortir de
l'europe comment demain nous en sortant
de l'europe
nous allons aider nos pêcheurs à
moderniser la flotte nous ne souhaitons
en qui nous avons même volé quoi nous
avons non non nous sommes contributeurs
nets alors payer si on parle des 600
millions
mais on a les moyens de terminer les
moyens de les aider non jugé qu'un débat
monsieur non mais oui c'est vrai que j'y
rejouerai pas porté nous avons voté et
moi je me félicite que pendant cinq ans
j'ai porté les politiques pêche au
conseil régional et pendant 50 c
politique pêche ont été adopté à la
quasi unanimité à chaque fois je crois
que nous avons porté aussi un cadre
juridique qui peut nous permettre demain
de renouveler la flottille nous avons
posé les bases de cet acte juridique de
ce cadre financier parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous ne sommes n'avons pas la
possibilité de pouvoir renouveler la
flottille par des collectivités les
collectivités ne peuvent pas financer le
renouvellement des des navires pour
autant ces navires ils connaissent de
gros problèmes ils ont 35 ans de moyenne
d'âge
nous devons assurer la sécurité des
marins nous devons assurer la sécurité
des navires et pour cela nous devons
améliorer la flotte améliorer participer
à la modernisation des navires de pêche
participer à la modernisation des
ateliers de mareyage participer à la
formation des jeunes et c'est pourquoi
et j'ai été surpris d'entendre la
candidate de debout la république dira
qu' il fallait aider à apporter des
formations pour les pêcheurs il y à un
lycée maritime et aquacole à cherbourg
nous en sommes fiers
nous étions il ya quelques temps encore
pour
ordonner des gilets de vêtements des
vêtements à flottabilité intégrée pour
les protéger parce que je crois que à la
fois la sécurité l'installation la
modernisation des ateliers et des
navires fait partie de ces axes que nous
souhaitons porter et développé pour
accompagner notre filière pêche avec
laquelle nous avons un dialogue régulier
et constant
si vous permettez à nos cours d'eau non
la langue qu'on aime qu'on aide les
pêcheurs qu'on modernise la flotte tout
à fait monsieur traverse avait raison et
c'est ce que j'ai proposé juste avant
par contre sur le financement on n'est
pas d'accord vous me vanter les 18
millions d'euros que donne lors que va
donner le référant à la région oui très
longue que l'avion ses contributeurs
automne à hauteur de 9 milliards d'euros
on verse 9 milliards d'euros par an de
support à l'europe qui nous retourne pas
voilà nous avons les moyens en france de
financer la filière pêche comme on a les
moyens de fabien c'est là où vous êtes
d'accord on a les moyens de financer la
grille l'élargir l'europe ne voulait pas
de laurent va falloir de robert jordan
l'europe on est content revue le
contributeur net à hauteur de 9
milliards on donne l'argent l'europe
pour que nous en retournent - c'est tous
viendront quand même
enfin au niveau du tréport voilà
monsieur jumelles et tête de liste
régionale et donc il est quand même
concerné par rapport à effectivement à
la localité où il se trouve et il ya un
rendez vous quand même de demander avec
le ministre de l'ecologie pour effet
pour pouvoir discuter effectivement
entre les pêcheurs et la mise en place
de ces éoliennes
il ya vraiment un travail de fond qui
est menée il ya un travail de fond a
continué on l'a dit tout à l'heure on
pourra pas sortir du nucléaire si on
travaille pas sur des énergies
effectivement parallèle et une énergie
en fait une diversification
donc il ya vraiment un travail de fond à
mener aujourd'hui il faut vraiment
amener le domaine de la pêche
autrement ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la pêche et de toute son
économie en fait et le pôle de la mer au
niveau régional il sera super important
pour que tout le monde puisse s'y
retrouver avec les commandes
les professionnels de la pêche les
professionnels des énergies il ya un
travail de fond et des recherches à
faire et un soutien au niveau du lycée
maritime
je pense qu'effectivement le lycée
maritime de cherbourg a besoin du
soutien la région il a besoin d'un
développement
on n'a pas beaucoup on a deux lycées en
sur la région on a fait quand est on à
comment donc cherbourg un peu plus loin
boulogne mais effectivement qui
travaillent mais qui passe sur le
territoire régional
donc on a vraiment une carte à jouer des
jeunes qui sont formés ces 130 jeunes
sur le territoire
donc je pense que c'est important de
soutenir ces jeunes pêcheurs une petite
précision on va vous donner la parole la
ville du rapport est dirigée par le
parti communiste qui soutient les
pêcheurs c'est une information c'était
important de le rappeler
on va peut-être faire avancer le débat
ce qu'on on a dix-sept minutes de débat
peut-être qu'on puisse parler des porcs
qui ont des potentiels aussi à exploiter
déplacer les hommes et les marchandises
en normandie 3 ports sont gérés
conjointement par les régions et les
départements caen ouistreham cherbourg
et dieppe la réforme obligera ses ports
à se regrouper dans le même syndicat
mixte le but est bien sûr de faire de
ces outils des instruments au service du
développement économique avec un élément
moteur le trafic transmanche et l'isf
eric lot de loches un ferry en
provenance de l'irlande qui accostent à
cherbourg rien de plus normal
et pourtant quelque chose a changé
depuis peu à bord les passagers les
marchandises sont de plus en plus
nombreux une progression de 17% côté
fret 6% pour le transport de personnes
chacun a ses raisons de préférer le
bateau à l'avion pour la pêche du
brochet du conte on a pas mal de
matériel à trimballer donc plutôt que
prendre l'avion le bateau est la
solution alternative quoi par rapport au
poids qu'on peut emmener et ce trait on
va dire c'est très bon marché l'espace
dans le bateau les cabines sont très
agréables et comme vous êtes en vacances
c'est super de ne pas subir le stress de
méreau port j'aime beaucoup la voiture
j'aime bien me balader avec mon véhicule
dans la campagne pour admirer le paysage
j'aime aller aux cheveux et parfois en a
profité pour apporter du vin français l'
irish ferries s'est implantée à
cherbourg au milieu des années 80 depuis
2007 le début de la crise économique la
compagnie n'avaient jamais observé une
telle augmentation de sa fréquentation
jusqu'à 10% de hausse
un bon parti cdu l économie en irlande
qui se porte très bien et à notre portée
s'est lié avec les problèmes de calais
cet été marc duchemin de blocage est un
autre problème c'est où l'esclave de
stack et autour de peur ici c'est
beaucoup plus calmes et plus de sécurité
pour les chauffeurs fret
les anglais aussi viennent en masse
toutes compagnies confondues
on compte 14 % de passagers en plus
entre le port manchois et le royaume-uni
et 66 % de hausse du fret sur la ligne
cherbourg poole hors du département
c'est toute la basse normandie qui
profitent de cette embellie économie
royaume uni et en est en belle
progression est donc tout ceci est bon
pour nous
la parité livre euro est favorable à ces
échanges donc ces trafics la sonde est
d'aider des trafics qui s'implantent en
réaction les compagnies renforcent leur
offre depuis janvier 2014 la irish
ferries a ouvert une ligne directe entre
cherbourg et dublin quant à la brittany
elle compte augmenter ses rotations avec
portsmouth dès le printemps 2016 david
margueritte
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
redynamiser les ports qui seront prêts
tous demain sous la compétence de la
région c'est ce que prévoit la loi note
oui en effet je pense que c'est une
bonne chose pour un certain nombre de
porcs qui doivent prendre une dimension
régionale je disais tout à l'heure qu'il
fallait défendre les intérêts des
pêcheurs normands on aurait pu parler de
la fichiers la filière conchylicole en
particulier de l'huître de normandie
qu'il faut labellisé mais sur la
question des ports nous sommes très
clairs nous le disons aujourd'hui
cherbourg le havre caen ouistreham
granville premier port en matière de
coquilles en france premier port pour le
bulot en europe et dieppe doivent être
aujourd'hui dans le giron de la région
cependant que des ports de proximité de
pêche artisanale doivent rester des
ports départementaux et que les
compétences doivent être partagés je
disais il faut défendre les intérêts des
ports normands pourquoi par celui de ce
projet qui est extrêmement dangereux
aujourd'hui en particulier pour le port
du havre
c'est le canal seine-nord ce canal
aujourd'hui a un double effet négatif
sur la normandie alors qu'il n'était pas
considéré comme priorité nationale 107
km entre paris et xavier
les grands ports du nord qu'on peut être
pas besoin de ça effectivement
exactement parce que en effet double
effet néfaste c'est d'abord que ce canal
qui est soutenu par le gouvernement
socialiste par la majorité régionale
socialiste est un canal qui aujourd'hui
va créer du trafic vers anvers en
particulier à qui on fait à qui on fait
un cadeau mais nous avons toujours dit
monsieur noël de notre côté et c'est là
le deuxième effet néfaste pour la
normandie que ce canal n'avait un sens
que si nous en profitions pour remettre
le havre en particulier avec une égalité
de concurrence c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui nous condamnons le
choix qui a été fait parce qu'il ya un
effet d'éviction puisque nous avons
préféré mettre 4 milliards 800 millions
dans le canal c'est en europe alors
qu'il y a aujourd'hui l'axé seine qui
est un projet formidable pour le havre
qui est à l'arrêt et qu'il doit
aujourd'hui permettre au havre pourtant
ce projet le permettrait au havre est
bien de bénéficier de desserte massifier
c'est la ligne nouvelle paris-normandie
c'est la kz gisors cerqueux également
c'est la desserte fluviale du havre ce
projet aujourd'hui la région socialiste
les deux régions socialistes haute et
basse normandie lui ont tourné le dos et
ont préféré miser sur le canal seine
nord europe qui pourtant n'était pas une
priorité et qui aujourd'hui comme le dit
le maire du havre et comme le dit hervé
morin
et bien ce projet en l'état actuel eh
bien c'est la mort des ambitions
portuaire française et en particulier
normand monsieur marguerite vous invite
si je me trompe
monsieur bah qui est le président du
conseil départemental même si en ce
moment il a quelques petits problèmes
par rapport à ça lui il est favorable au
maintien de la responsabilité
départementale des ports de la manche ou
6 sauf si on est tout à fait d'accord et
en face sur la question du port de
granville pour la question de la manche
qui a une dimension régionale qui attend
des travaux d'extension avec 500 places
supplémentaires et nous sommes d'accord
et d'ailleurs j'en profite pour le dire
c'est que si la majorité régionale
demain et bien nous la conduisons avec
hervé morin et bien les cinq
départements où la même couleur
politique ce qui permettra de faciliter
les choses pour se partager les
compétences c'est une des forces de
notre région socialistes ont dix pendant
quelques années
j'aime bien louer vous êtes en déficit
de temps alors comment rendre les
portugais mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut
jouer la complémentarité est ce que
chacun d'avoir une spécificité est ce
qu'on peut imaginer des déplacements
entre les hommes d'un port à l'autre
écoutez je crois qu on a le devoir
aujourd'hui en tant que collectivité de
faire attention à l'argent public je
crois que tous nos concitoyens nous le
demandent donc jouer la concurrence
en normandie des ports entre eux je
pense que ce serait incohérent
donc c'est évidemment de jouer la
complémentarité le reportage nous
montrer qu'on avait une relance du
trafic transmanche en termes de en
termes de pearson choix que c'est bien
et il faut continuer à l'encourager
tout comme aussi il faudrait encourager
le trafic le fret le transport de
marchandise parce que là par contre
c'est plus difficile et on évoquait tout
à l'heure est grave pour donner un
chiffre
4 % de fret uniquement tout à fait qu
explique peut-être effectivement qu'il
est le huitième pour européen et à
cherbourg on a du mal
enfin voilà on a du mal à évacuer ces
marchandises est alors le sud
effectivement donc après ce fait le lien
avec l'intermodalité et le ferroviaire
et là on a le même si on n'a pas la
compétence du fret au niveau de la
région
il ya un rôle à jouer puisque c'est un
impact sur les trains les trains
régionaux donc à l'heure où on doit
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre je crois qu'il faut absolument
encourager le trafic maritime c'est
voilà c'est beaucoup moins impactants et
puis après je crois qu'on a une carte et
c'est peut-être pas pour rien que les
irlandais les anglais aussi reviennent
reviennent chez nous c'est qu'on a une
carte touristique à jouer voilà on est
une région la normandie très diversifié
avec un patrimoine touristique kéké
riche que ce soit nos paysages notre
gastronomie notre patrimoine
donc on a une vraie carte à jouer et
donc voilà il faut vraiment communiquer
et travailler sur cette piste là alors
que ce travers jouer les cours viennent
quand même sur le canal seine nord pour
nos téléspectateurs qui savent pas
obligatoirement l'importance de ce
projet vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
national grid c'est plus de 2 milliards
400 millions avec une participation de
l'europe
c'est important de près d'un milliard et
là je pense que le représentant du front
national va encore dire que l'europe
intervient est très largement dans les
régions quelque part il aura peut-être
pas tout à fait autant mais en même
temps cet argent on en est besoin alors
à droite vous l'avez dit mais à gauche
également je pense à monsieur bouillon
christophe bouillon qui est député de la
seine-maritime
je pense au maire communiste de
gonfreville l'orcher monsieur le coq et
puis d'autres élus de droite comme de
gauche sur la pointe de caux franchement
ce
je ne passe absolument pas quelle est
votre position à vous est ce que vous
pensez véritablement comme le pensent
vos amis socialistes de la région
parisienne et du nord pas de calais que
c'est bien pour l'économie
voilà ou alors est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est véritablement comme le disent
certains de façon un peu triviale une
pompe à fric qui va avantager
véritablement les ports anvers et
rotterdam
protégez moi de mes amis mes ennemis je
m'en charge c'est un projet qui était
portée à l'origine par monsieur borloo
c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui je crois que
le canal seine-nord il est de nature à
désengorger aussi le trafic containers
que nous n'arriverons pas à porter
aujourd'hui et je crois qu'il faut
travailler à la complémentarité entre
les ports et je crois que c'est ça qui
est important aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
nous avons des infrastructures
portuaires
nous avons une infrastructure
aujourd'hui sur le territoire normand
qui fonctionne merveilleusement bien
avec les départements mais je dois dire
que pn à aujourd'hui avec ce que confère
la loi d'autres pans normands associés
est une structure qui depuis 2007 a
permis à ce que nous puissions
accompagner la puissance portuaire sur
le territoire normand demain sur
l'ensemble de la normandie
je souhaite que pn à puissent continuer
à travailler à développer ses ports et à
offrir une complémentarité entre les
différents hinterland cherbourg c'est un
petit hinterland par rapport bien
évidemment au port du havre ou au port
de dieppe mais pour autant chacun doit
trouver sa place que ce soit sur la
plaisance que ce soit sur les métiers de
la pêche que ce soit sur le fret où
l'industrie et je crois que là aussi en
lien avec le canal seine-nord les ports
ici les ports normands ont un intérêt
particulier à accompagner ce projet
c'est ce que nous souhaitons en tous les
cas bien évidemment mais je crois que
d'abord il va falloir résoudre
lorsque la normandie aura été réunifiée
résoudre la problématique de
l'appartenance portuaire quel port iront
au département est ce que nous devons
spécialisé un certain nombre de ports on
le sait le port de granville est plutôt
spécialisé dans le boulot dans la
coquille saint jacques laporte coquille
et est ce que demain il doit prendre la
compétence régionale
c'est cette vision d'ensemble que nous
devons porter je crois que nous devons
continuer à garder la structure que nous
avons aujourd'hui
pn à qui a su montrer son efficacité qui
a su remettre à l'endroit
sinon si l'on peut dire les intérêts
portuaire
de la normandie et de je dirais
constitué ici sur le tourisme
on est ici à la cité de la mer et on
sait que c'est en train un développement
continu est en train de se faire
notamment sur le trafic des des
paquebots et je crois que là aussi nous
avons des cartes des cartes à jouer
nous avons ici à cherbourg les cinq
ports maritimes milly enfin militaire de
pêche de commerce industriels etc de
plaisance et je crois que nous devons
capitaliser sur ces différentes
spécialisations pour faire en sorte que
notre deuxième façade maritime française
la normandie soit au rendez vous de ses
ambitions demain sur jacques noël quelle
place quel rôle pour les ports normands
alors moi je vais revenir sur le sur le
sur le canal seine-nord pour nous nous
soutiendrons projets si et seulement si
il ya un investissement massif qui est
fait sur le port du havre qui a acquis
en puces la mise en place d'un
protectionnisme sur ce sur ce canal
c'est à dire un péage douaniers qui est
qui permettrait de qui taxerait les
bateaux étrangers pour favoriser
justement les transporteurs français et
normand et pour favoriser le port du
havre mais si c'est si ces choses ne
sont pas mises en place
fatalement sur les ports normands le
havre et rouen en pâtiront nous nous
sommes pour renforcer en parlant de
rouen qui est le premier port ce qu'une
personne ne l'a signalé mes premiers pas
se rallier d'europe nous sommes pour
renforcer donc dans l'hinterland du port
de rouen
les liaisons ferroviaires notamment avec
la région centre la région de la beauce
qui est le plus gros producteur de
céréales pour permettre justement
l'acheminement et l'exportation des
céréales de la beauce pour augmenter le
trafic pour ce à rouen et ensuite donc
créé un partenariat entre le port de
caen mais blainville-sur-orne l'analyse
la partie containers avec le port du
havre pour justement essayer d'y
multiplier les possibilités et les
moyens de ses ports la voie sachant que
cherbourg pour nous
de par sa situation géographique a des
atouts pour le transmanche a les atouts
pour le tourisme qu'il faut re
développer et puisque c'est une c'est
quelque chose qui était abandonnée quand
même depuis depuis quelques années on va
parler effectivement de cette manne
financière qui vient des ports le
tourisme il débarque du transmanche mais
aussi deux gros paquebot lors d'escales
l'an passé plus de deux millions de
croisiéristes ont débarqué en normandie
pour quelques heures ou à vous encore à
cherbourg puisque ce sont des ports en
eau profonde mais caen ouistreham sont
aussi de jouer cette carte à son niveau
puisque deux beaux et gros bateaux à
quai bien ça peut rapporter gros
hélène jacques avec charles bizarre
lorsqu'on évoque la croisière en
normandie
il ya d'abord cette image là de
véritables mastodontes qui viennent en
force au havre le port le plus prisé
les gros paquebots ils font une centaine
d'escales à l'année soit plus de deux
cent mille passagers il est aussi
cherbourg une trentaine de navires et
80000 croisiéristes ont débarqué l'an
dernier honfleur
mais il ne faudrait pas oublier le petit
poucet le port de caen ouistreham qui
joue dans un autre registre
complémentaires la capacité des bateaux
que nous envisageons avec nous
souhaitons accueillir va plutôt autour
de 300 à 400 croisiéristes c'est-à-dire
moindre mais ce sont des croisiéristes
un peu plus exigeants c'est à dire que
ayant un fort potentiel d'achat sur la
ville et dans la région
nous nous devons d'avoir un accueil de
qualité de cinq navires accueillis par
an le port voudrait passer à 15 escales
pour 2010 est le tout nouveau club de
croisière qui réunit différentes
collectivités veut attirer plus de
croisiéristes une escale c'est en
moyenne 100 euros dépensés par personne
il faut séduire
nous avons une richesse qui n'a
peut-être pas toujours été mise en avant
le patrimoine et la possibilité aussi de
partir faire une excursion
d'aller déguster du calvados dun pays
d'auge d'un visiter le musée de bayeux
de fermer plages du débarquement
autre argument le canal de caen à la mer
et son célèbre pont de pegasus bridge
cinq points d'accostage ont été retenus
depuis trois ans des travaux ont été
réalisés
c'est pas loin de 30 millions d'euros
qui ont été investis sur le port de
ouistreham pour conforter le sas
améliorer l'accueil le cap et donner la
priorité de l'association convaincre
maintenant les compagnies maritimes et
les armateurs beaucoup de touristes 2
millions entre cherbourg et le havre
mais peu reste dans les villes
portuaires comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour eux les séduire peut-être
pour qu'ils les inciter à dépenser sur
place va peut-être en montant des
partenariats plus renforcée avec les
avec les commerçants et des villes
concernées
et puis aussi avec les producteurs les
producteurs locaux les producteurs de la
région peut être monter un un espèce de
d'une espèce de commande de deux
présentoirs de village voilà de comment
pour pour vanter les produits de la
normandie et pour pour faire découvrir
les produits ce qui ce qui sera une
source de de commandes de revenus
supplémentaires pour nos pronos
producteurs locaux
nous bénéficions aussi en ce moment
d'une dune livre sterling qui est assez
élevé les anglais ont trouvé beaucoup de
pouvoir d'achat et c'est important de
les faire venir puisque pour eux
maintenant c'est de nouveau si je puis
dire rentable de venir en france
alors on a vu avec che luc effectivement
lui le débarquement donc les américains
et elle a déjà mais ils reviennent ça
c'est une chose qui est certaine tout à
l'heure de ce travers évoqué un label en
ce qui concerne justement les produits
de la mer est-ce qu'on peut monsieur
marguerite imaginait aussi je disais en
début d'émission que les normands
étaient pas toujours très fier d'être
normands ils ont peut-être tort
d'ailleurs imaginer un label du tourisme
véritablement qui fonctionne mais alors
là il faut se mettre d'accord parce que
des fois les gens c'est un petit peu
dans les pattes quand même c'est
d'ailleurs tout le sens de notre
campagne nous c'est de créer cette
identité normande et cette marque
normandie le tourisme c'est des
potentialités de croissance très
importante à l'horizon 2030 à peu près
3,3 pour cent de croissance touristique
les croisières c'est une potentialité le
premier point d'entrée pour les
croisiéristes et la ville dans laquelle
il arrive on constate qu'à cherbourg 4 %
seulement restent dans la ville à
honfleur 50% c510 l'ont d'ailleurs sur
l'accueil des croisiéristes dans les
villes respectives
nous ce que nous disons c'est que nous
voulons développer les boucles
touristique la normande
c'est le tourisme mémoriel donc
historique c'est les plages du
débarquement bien sûr le tourisme
culturel nous voulons développer cela un
peu comme le fait marseille provence
métropole avec des partenariats
institutionnels et des professionnels de
la filière touristique
bref mutualisé créer des synergies et
faire en sorte que le tourisme soit un
vecteur de développement pour la
normandie
merci david margueritte je crois vous
avez le mot de la fin qui nous reste que
quelques secondes merci à tous d'avoir
débattu sur l'économie de la mer c'est
la fin de cette voie est libre consacré
donc l économie la mer prochain rendez
vous samedi prochain à 11h05 avec vous
feelgood est sûre vu plusieurs sera au
musée d'art moderne
andré malraux au havre et nous parlerons
de l'économie et de l'emploi forcément
en normandie
très bon samedi à vous
on